When you think of the biggest, most money-making,
merchandised and capitalized game series of
all time, there’s only one franchise that
comes to mind: Pokémon.
For the entirety of its lifespan, Pokémon
has been a financial powerhouse, and every
year the series seems to grow in popularity
and revenue.
Whether it’s games, cards, a show, toys,
or even Pokémon-branded clothes that you
need, you’ll have no difficulty finding
a product that appeals to you.
Everyone knows Pikachu’s face, and nearly
every child born within the past twenty years
has had firsthand experience with Pokémon.
It is, in some respects, inescapable.
If you hate Pokémon, too bad, because this
little electric mouse runs this world, and
you’ll just have to sit back and deal with
it.
One could even say that Pokémon is uncontainable.
Which poses quite the issue for the SCP Foundation,
who work tirelessly to ensure that no facet
of life is withheld from its reach.
But the Foundation rarely deals with major
franchises, beloved by millions upon millions
of people across the world, and for good reason
too.
An anomaly tied in with a major franchise
poses a lot of problems on the containment
side.
Namely, its ability to spread uncontrollably
and without care, being witnessed by countless
individuals before the Foundation comes up
with a way to contain it.
Global supply lines have to be interrupted
to prevent anomalous products from hitting
shelves, corporate espionage committed, and
most of all, a massively expensive cover-up
operation to remove said products from consumer’s
hands.
If the Foundation had to deal with an anomaly
affecting the Pokémon franchise, there’s
no telling how out of hand it would get before
they’d be able to get a handle on the situation.
But in 2019, that’s exactly what happened.
Today we’re going to be looking at SCP-5254,
an anomaly dubbed “Gotta Catch ‘Em All”
in the Foundation’s database.
The year was 2019, the place Japan, the home
country of the Pokémon franchise.
Every year since 2014, the Pokémon Company
has held a festival named “Pikachu Outbreak!”
in the city of Yokohama, in which hundreds
of costumed actors dressed as Pikachu would
crowd the city’s Mirai district, and perform,
dance, and even participate in a parade.
The event was intended to celebrate the Pokémon
franchise and promote whatever the latest
venture the series is pushing, whether it's
a game, a movie, or something else.
The festival proved to be successful and has
been held every year since.
After all, who wouldn’t want to see a legion
of Pikachu running amok through the streets?
But the fun would be short-lived during the
2019 Outbreak, where something incredibly
unusual occurred.
Picture this, a large crowd, hundreds of fans
dressed in Pokémon-themed attire, standing
on both sides of the streets.
Men, women, children, anyone and everyone
came to see the Pikachu Outbreak, and they
weren’t disappointed.
Parading down the street was a hoard of Pikachu,
just as advertised.
They danced, bounced, and walked together
in routine fashion, all while the crowd cheered
and yelled.
Even the spectators in the crowd showed their
spirit with Pikachu-themed hats, yellow tails
fastened to their backs, and yellow face masks
with two electrified red circles on the cheeks.
The parade proceeded as normal, that is, until
one of the parading Pikachu started behaving
oddly.
It began as out-of-sync movements, strange
wobbles and deviations from the parade path.
For the heavily coordinated Outbreak festival,
this was unusual.
The rest of the Pikachu line danced to the
beat of the music, sticking in formation as
best as they could.
Then, as if pushed by an invisible force,
the strange Pikachu raced forward, diving
head first into the crowd, barreling into
the group of people and eventually colliding.
The crowd moved out of the way, slightly shocked
- no pun intended - by what had occurred.
But then it happened again!
Two more Pikachu ran into the crowd.
And then again!
Over fifteen Pikachu ran themselves into the
crowd, resulting in a massive disruption of
the parade, and the shut-down of the event
entirely.
The Foundation quickly caught wind of this,
and sent their closest operatives to assess
the situation in a controlled fashion.
After blocking off the crowd and shutting
down the event, another strange detail emerged,
one that ensured the Foundation that there
had to be some sort of anomalous significance
to what was occurring here.
Some of the crowd members involved in the
collisions were suffering very peculiar medical
injuries, namely blunt force trauma way stronger
than what a clash with a costumed actor would
induce, and severe electrical burns.
The Foundation was positive there was something
occurring here, and with a franchise as vast
and popular as Pokémon, they didn’t want
to take any chances.
Immediately, Foundation agents began collecting
information on the event, setting up probes
in the offices of Gamefreak and The Pokémon
Company, and attempting to get to the bottom
of what exactly happened during the parade.
When the Foundation interrogated the 15 mascots
who collided with the crowd, they were shocked
to learn that they weren’t mascots at all,
but instead fully separate entities that resembled
the Pikachu costume.
X-Rays revealed that their once human skeletons
were now fused to their costumes, and touching
them produced a minor electric shock.
The performers had become Pikachu, and now
they were unable to be removed from their
costumes.
Every captured instance had expired before
the Foundation was able to fully study and
discern what was occuring to them, their bodies
unable to support themselves after such a
lethal, extreme transformation.
Later observation found that the synthetic
components of the costumes, such as the cotton
and plastic composites, had fused into their
flesh and muscle tissue.
Bodily fluids were found to contain foriegn
DNA and numerous strange structures, to the
point where an ordinary human’s genetic
makeup would be incomparable and unrecognizable
with that affected by the anomaly.
The Foundation tentatively opened a file on
SCP-5254, the anomalous transformation of
a human into the rough approximation of a
Pokémon character, and began carrying out
tests to determine what occurred during the
festival.
What caused SCP-5254 to manifest?
It couldn’t have been random, could it?
The Foundation needed to know.
One theory that researchers working on the
SCP-5254 file had come up with was that it
was the large gathering of Pokémon related
clothing worn by the crowd that prompted the
transformation.
But that begged the question, why hadn’t
this occurred at any previous festivals or
large Pokémon related gatherings?
It was a huge franchise, there were absolutely
more events that had masses of costumed fans
donning Pokémon-related gear.
Did something happen in recent years to manifest
this anomaly?
The only way to find out was to conduct testing.
In one of the easier experiments that a D-Class
personnel was tasked with carrying out, the
Foundation ordered a group of them to dress
entirely in Pokémon-related clothing, which
the Foundation provided themselves.
Some items, such as a full-bodied Gardevoir
onesie, were taken from Dr. Clef’s personal
collection itself!
No, he is not taking further questions.
Anyways, with the D-Class looking utterly
ridiculous in full Pokémon getup, the observing
researchers began their tests.
First was a D-Class outfitted solely in a
“Pokémon Pikachu Big Face with Ears Hat.”,
as the product’s official title stated.
After standing there for 15 minutes, the Foundation
determined that there was no discernible effect.
Next was a “Pokemon Detective Pikachu Cosplay
Mask Latex”
, which the Foundation placed on the same
D-Class.
After another 15 minutes with no changes observed,
the D-Class closed the experiment, remarking
that it was stupid.
The Research team told the D-Class to remain
composed and to just continue along with the
trials unless they wanted to be reprimanded.
After that was a “D'BOON Adult Onesie Pikachu
Animal Pajamas”.
A few researchers held back laughter as the
hardened, muscular D-Class in front of them
stood around in a Pikachu onesie that barely
fit him.
After asking him how he was feeling, the subject
quickly turned aggressive.
The results from this test were deemed inconclusive,
due to researchers being unable to determine
if the quick snap in anger was a result of
a potential anomaly or whether the D-Class
was just getting fed up with having to do
this.
For the next test, two D-Class were brought
in, clad in Pikachu onesies.
The D-class were placed four meters apart.
After a period of time, a tingling sensation
was reported in the arms and legs, akin to
that pins-and-needles feeling you get when
your arms fall asleep, or when you get shocked
by static electricity.
The next one had four D-Class, all dressed
similar to the previous group.
Instead of being meters apart, they were asked
to hold hands, which the D-Class begrudgingly
did.
Severe migraines were reported, as well as
“throbbing pain in the cranium and lower
jowls of the face”.
Near the tailbone, some D-Class reported a
dull aching.
Most curiously, several areas on their body
had begun to change in skin coloration.
Namely, a mustard yellow.
Eventually, the Foundation began to test for
an affiliation or emotional connection to
the Pokémon franchise.
Could that be the key to understanding SCP-5254?
Another four D-Class, all noted Pokémon fans,
were brought in.
One had owned a copy of Pokémon Yellow for
the GameBoy when he was a child, and another
had a high-leveled account on the Pokémon
GO app.
The Foundation discovered that these D-Class
reported muscle spasms along the extent of
their spines, with one complaining of tightness
in their chest before coughing up tufts of
fur, and another physically recoiling upon
an attempt at physical contact, in fear they
would electrically shock the researcher.
These experiments proved to be fruitful for
the Foundation, as they learned that SCP-5254
was irreversible.
Removing the clothing or items did not result
in the transformative properties of SCP-5254
reversing.
Furthermore, the testing went on beyond this
point, just to cover all possible bases of
what SCP-5254 was before the details were
properly ironed out.
A total of 56 D-Class personnel were lost
during these experiments, and testing paused
due to concern by Foundation higher-ups of
a potential security breach and damage being
done to the site’s power grid.
But most importantly, a connection to the
Pokémon brand was what enabled SCP-5254 to
truly take effect.
That’s what occurred at the Outbreak Festival,
where the bodies of costumed Pikachu fanatics
fused into their costumes and barreled towards
the crowd.
Now that the Foundation understood the “how”
of SCP-5254, they still had to get to the
“why”.
Even by Foundation standards, this is a pretty
odd and random anomaly.
Did the answers lie with Gamefreak or The
Pokémon Company itself?
After the Festival incident, the Foundation
put web-probes into the servers of The Pokémon
Company’s Japanese branch, and had their
web crawlers scan through millions of correspondence
emails to find any hint of unusual behavior.
A series of emails between major shareholders
in the company were found.
The first was from Kimishima Tatsumi, the
CEO of Nintendo, the overseeing company above
the Pokémon company, and Tsunekazu Ishihara,
the latter’s CEO.
It read:
“Do not ask questions.
If this "Ser Viper" wants manpower for his
project, give it to him.
Our society will not miss these irrelevant
individuals.
“He, whoever he claims to be, may be charging
us a small fortune, but at least he seems
genuinely interested in bringing our creations
to life.”
Bringing their creations to life?
How curious.
The email was dated to 2017, two years before
the outbreak incident.
The Foundation decided to dig deeper.
Another email from 2017, exchanged between
the two individuals months after the first:
“Tuesday will mark the fifth visit by the
Fukushima Orphanage to our headquarters.
I told the press it's part of our global outreach
programme to spread the joy of Pokémon to
the rest of the world.
Early results have been positive.
I should have a specimen to show you the next
time we meet in Tokyo.
Your daughter likes Eevee, yes?”
It seemed like these executives were talking
about creating real Pokémon, somehow!
What did the orphanage have to do with this?
Another email read:
“Play anytime, anywhere, with anyone.
Yes, the slogan for the Switch is very apt
for what we're trying to accomplish.
Your marketing team deserves a raise.
I am pleased to report Pokémon Go2 has hit
750 million unique downloads in July and 5
million daily average users this past week.
The popularity of the franchise continues
to grow.
Think of the possibilities once we integrate
Augmented Reality (AR) technology into the
project: Altaria as a clean and efficient
form of air transportation, Charizard serving
in the Self-Defense Forces, and yes, Pikachu
making our reliance on nuclear energy a thing
of the past.
Soon, Pokémon will come to life before our
very eyes.”
The Foundation couldn’t believe something
as absurd as creating real Pokémon was a
genuine possibility for these companies.
It was going on right beneath their noses.
But the emails from 2018 began to show cracks
in the Pokémon Company and Nintendo’s plans.
“The accidents are growing in number.
Are you sure "Ser Viper" has everything under
control?
We cannot hide these incidents from the public
forever.
We already have our hands full trying to catch
the runaways.
If we don't take action soon, more people
will get hurt.
Or worse: the Pokémon brand will be tarnished
forever.”
Whoever was responsible for creating Pokémon
for the companies was going by the alias of
“Ser Viper”, and it seemed like their
experiments weren’t working the way they
planned.
An email directly addressed to Ser Viper fully
encapsulated the Pokémon Company’s disgust
at the individual once they realized the experiments
weren’t succeeding in creating an immersive,
fun Pokémon experience in the real world.
“You promised us Pokémon as pets and companions
- not these mutations!
I've had to recall thousands of faulty merchandise,
with tens of thousands of defective products
still circulating the market.
Just what kind of sorcery have you forced
upon our hands?
The government is breathing down my neck,
Tatsumi-san has had to resign and I'm starting
to hear about this "Foundation" poking around.
Tell me the truth - is there any way to reverse
the effects?
Or have you doomed us all?
“SerViper1995”, as their screen name read,
responded with this:
“I don't know what to tell you.
I've given the people what they want - only
true fans will get a Pokémon of their own.
Your company was the very best at building
your brand.
Congratulations.
Today, Pokémon has taken over our hearts
and minds.
Perhaps one day, we will see them take over
the world.”
And with that, the company had cut off all
communication with “Ser Viper”.
But now, the Foundation had to get to the
bottom of what was happening in those boardrooms
and offices.
Making Pokémon in real life?
It sounded crazy, and from the way the emails
were worded, they had apparently succeeded
in making something, even if they considered
it a failure.
Three months later, after all of the research
on SCP-5254 was conducted, the Overseer Council
authorized a raid on the Pokémon Company
offices in Minato City, Tokyo, on June 16th,
2019.
From the way the emails were written, they
had reason to believe that civilians were
potentially being held against their will
and used in these experiments.
Failure to deal with them now could potentially
spell disaster if they got out, and the cause
of SCP-5254 wasn’t immediately neutralized.
Following the Japanese government’s authorization
of the raid, a Foundation Mobile Task Force
detachment from Epsilon-11 “Nine Tailed
Fox” was stationed outside the offices.
The task force broke into the building through
the fire exit, and promptly cleared out tourists
and civilians from the area.
During the raid, they encountered a large
creature that resembled a Charizard, an orange,
fire-breathing dragon Pokémon, that stopped
them in their tracks in the hallway.
Wings, an elongated snout, the perfect color,
it looked exactly as if a Charizard had leapt
from the screen and into real life.
It spewed combustible, orange liquid at the
team, but they quickly dispatched it with
ease, using their weapons to put some water
on the Pokémon’s fire.
Well, the water was actually a salvo of bullets,
but the metaphor still works.
Most of the building was cleared, and those
inside detained for further questioning.
But then the team came to a set of steel doors.
Inside was a room littered with toys, brightly
colored walls, and large, metal cages.
But then the team came to a set of steel doors.
Inside was a room littered with toys, brightly
colored walls, and large, metal cages.
Ser Viper’s failed experiments, clearly.
Entities at various stages of SCP-5254 transformation.
One resembled a Vulpix, a fox pokemon.
It had engorged eye sockets and blood flowing
down their cheeks.
Another cage had a boy with cheek-bones protruding
high and sideways, pulling thin skin over
the rest of his face.
Another had a large bear-like entity with
serrated claws, with alternate fingers peeling
and decomposing underneath.
Most horrifying of all were a pair inside
cages near the other side of the room.
A girl with an extended, flattened, engorged
tongue, which pooled drool on the floor at
her feet.
She was made to resemble a Lickitung, a Pokemon
with a similarly large tongue.
Another was an elongated purple snake, like
the Pokemon Arbok, except its head was that
of a toddler.
It writhed back and forth, bawling and screaming.
The team requested immediate medical pick-up
to remove the specimens from the room.
Wherever Ser Viper, the individual responsible
for this, was, the Foundation could not locate
them.
The Foundation contained the experiments,
and detained Mr. Ishihara, the CEO of the
company.
He was brought back to the research site for
an interview.
Ishihara claimed not to know of the experiment's
existence, but he quickly broke down.
When asked about Ser Viper, Ishihara had this
to say.
“We didn't ask too many questions.
When we found out what he was doing to the
children, we terminated his contract immediately.
But the damage had been done.
Later, we discovered he had already tampered
with our production lines and distribution
infrastructure.
At this point, it's impossible to tell which
products have been affected on the market.”
Following this, global coordination between
Nintendo, the Foundation, and The Pokemon
Company in an attempt to figure out a solution
to products that were affected by SCP-5254
is presently ongoing.
All attempts to contact “SerViper1995”’s
email result in the same automated message:
“Happy hunting.
But even you can't catch 'em all.”
Now go watch “SCP-3108 The Nerfing Gun”
and “SCP-387 - The Living Lego” for more
Kid-friendly Franchises twisted into anomalous
entities contained by the SCP Foundation!